a multimedia extravaganza featuring
water lasers and pyrotechnics
synchronized with music welcome to ocwen
REO Europe's biggest mobile water show
Thunder sentai it's pretty incredible
what you can do with water I've never
seen anything like this before on it
goes in the fob the way that the colors
and the water interact is really amazing
beautiful special ghazal chinami vago it
was amazing the lighting the fireworks
and excellent musicians
it's an unusual experience for the
musicians from the Pink Floyd show UK
there are no strangers to mega events
but what's different here is that
they're sharing the spotlight
I love it I think it's brilliant the the
actual show itself the akron area the
water and lasers it's complete
spectacles looks insane and just the way
it matches up with the music it's it's
perfect the thing fluids music up an REO
premiered in 2012 it since featured a
wide range of arrow spanning
international music acts
such as the cover band Pink Floyd show
UK their repertoire comprises hits from
the band's 30-year history the music and
the special effects are in perfect sync
for sho designer Misha Anton precision
is everything
something for CS it's very stressful
because there's so much to take into
account especially the band I have to
keep an eye on the technological side of
it but I also need to follow what's
going on onstage I'm in charge of the
water the pyrotechnics and the lighting
fire please it took aqua na Rios 100
strong team an entire week to set up
they laid 15,000 meters of cable and
transported 300 tons of equipment
the whole system is about the size of a
small swimming pool it contains half a
million liters of water
think it enough i discard I'd say that
sustainability is an issue for everyone
these days wasting water would be
disastrous if we pump the water into the
pool and we work with it ya Bob I we
don't add any chemicals and when the
show's over we make sure it goes back
into the groundwater with unpack them
come to orthopedic for work the show is
a technological challenge and the
conditions are especially daunting
problem is actually more the cold Angus
Decatur damn we have lots of nozzles
that have to be sent by hand so they're
perfectly aligned and then you have to
wade into the pool because the nozzles
only work if they're full of water so
you have to deal with a cold and try to
overcome as a charge with that case get
up finding a super windy
the effort that goes into the show is
matched by the numbers of the audience
over 120,000 people have already seen it
I
during the show eighty-five thousand
liters of water shoot into the air from
170 spouts in seven fountains
the think Floyd show UK band will only
be part of the show's Berlin
performances but once flowing the water
can't be stopped in coming days it will
be gushing to the sounds of various
epochs and the sights of a unique
underwater journey